وكانت المندوبه البريطانيه في مجلس الامن
الدولي باربرا ودوارد قد قالت ان روسيا
دمرت بالصواريخ الثقيله مخازن الحبوب في
اوديسا وعبر اوكرانيا واكدت ان لدى لندن
معلومات تشير الى ان روسيا قد تهاجم السفن
المدنيه في البحر الاسود
اعتقد ان استخدام مثل هذه الاسلحه الثقيله
لتدمير مخازن الحبوب يظهر ان استراتيجيه
روسيا تتضمن استخدام امدادات الغذاء
العالميه كالسلاح تشير معلوماتنا الى ان
الجيش الروسي قد يستهدف السفن المدنيه في
البحر الاسود كما يوجد لدينا معلومات ان
روسيا نشرت الغاما بحريه قرب الموانئ
الاوكرانيه ونتفق مع تقييم الولايات
المتحده بان هذا جهد منسق لالقاء اللوم
على اوكرانيا لتنفيذ اي هجمات على السفن
المدنيه في البحر الاسود